in recent years artificial intelligence
and machine learning AIML have permitted
every aspect of Our Lives
if you are a programmer chances are you
have begun utilizing GitHub co-pilot an
AI tool that transform natural language
problems into coding suggestions
streamlining the programming processes
as a writer you have encountered open
eigpd3 or similar Auto Progressive
language models that leverage deep
learning to generate text assembling
human language many of us have dedicated
a few hours to experimenting with Dali
2. AIML power text to image generator
capable of producing intricate users
based on the most unusual request
not only is the Dalai to exponentially
more powerful but it also has the
potential to revolutionize the field of
digital art Dali to impact on digital
artists illustrator or graphic designer
career imagine being able to create a
highly realistic image within seconds
using an app
these technologies have significant real
world application with far-reaching
applications
as our lives continues to become more
convenient with each passing day AIML
has made remarkable advancement in
relatively short span of time with its
exponentially growth business world the
adoption and the utilization of AIML
technologies have the potential to
provide businesses with the long lasting
competitive Advantage according to the
recent studies machine learning job
posted have increased by staggering 344
percent in past five years
companies across the Globes are actively
seeking professionals who can harness
the power of data and build intelligent
systems the average salary in United
States is 150 000 in the US and 15 lakhs
per annum in India
so why wait accelerate your career in Ai
and ml with our comprehensive
postgraduate program in AIML again
expertise in machine learning deep
learning NLP computer vision and
reinforcement learning you will receive
a prestigious certificate exclusive
alumni membership and hackathons and ask
me anything session by IBM with three
Capstone project and 25 plus industry
project using real data sets from
Twitter Uber and more you will gain
practical experience master classes by
party faculty and IBM expert ensure
top-notch educations simply launch job
assist helps you get noticed by Leading
companies live session on AI trends like
chatgpt generative Ai and explainable AI
this program covers strategic python
supervised and unsupervised learning NLP
neural network computer vision JNS Keras
tensorflow and many more skills so why
wet enroll now and unlock exciting Ai
and ml opportunities the course link is
in the description box below so let's
take a minute to hear from our Learners
who have experienced massive success in
their careers we need to keep updating
your skills on a regular basis no matter
what level you're at a recently
completed the professional certificate
program in Ai and machine learning from
Simply learn in partnership with Purdue
University the course material was
comprehensive and the faculty was
extremely experienced The Faculty was
able to adjust their teaching style in
order to cater to the overall skill set
of the class in the rapidly evolving
world of technology it's important to
keep up Skilling for every working
professional stay relevant continue
learning
with that having a set so hey everyone
welcome to Simply on YouTube channel
today we will discuss the perfect
roadmap to become an AIML engineer
this tried and tested approach should
benefit you in the long run so without
further Ado let's get started and while
we are going through the roadmap if you
find our video interesting and if these
are the types of videos you like to
watch then hit that subscribe button and
click on the Bell to be the first to get
notified of our newest videos tutorials
so here is a comprehensive step-by-step
guide to learn machine learning in 2023
so first is familiarize yourself with
the fundamentals of machine learning
second acquire Proficiency in python or
our programming languages
third gain knowledge of essential python
libraries for machine learning
and the fourth one is learn and
Implement various machine learning
algorithms
and the fifth one is Master the concept
and implementation of neural networks
and the sixth one is engage in Hands-On
projects to apply your knowledge and
reinforce your understanding so now
let's explore each step of the roadmap
one by one so number one is familiarize
yourself with the fundamentals of
machine learning in the initial stages
of learning to drive we are familiarize
with the different elements varieties
and regulation pertaining to operating a
car so it is essential to delve into the
fundamentals of machine learning to
understand what lies ahead and the
extents of knowledge required so here
are some highly recommended resources
for mastering the fundamentals of
machine learning the first one is
understanding machine learning from
Theory to algorithms and the second one
is mathematics of machine learning and
the third one is basics of machine
learning course so now let's move on
this step too
so step number two is acquire
Proficiency in python or our programming
language to excel in the field of
artificial intelligence and machine
learning it is crucial to develop a
strong command of python or our
programming languages both Python and R
are widely used in the data science
Community due to their versatility and
extensive library for scientific
Computing when he possesses a strong
command of python or R you have a solid
foundation for implementing machine
learning algorithm analyzing data and
building predictive models it contains
understanding the syntax data structure
control flow and function specific to
The Chosen programming language
so let's move to the third step which is
gaining knowledge of essential python
libraries for machine learning once you
have acquired Proficiency in python as a
part of your machine Learning Journey
the subsequent steps involves
familiarizing yourself with the
essential python libraries crucial for
working with data and implementing
machine learning solution
so the key python library is that you
should learn from machine learning are
first is numpy a fundamental library for
numerical Computing that involves
support for handling large arrays and
matrices along with a wide range of
mathematical function the second one is
pandas a powerful library for data
manipulation and Analysis offering a
convenient data structure and function
to handle structured data efficiently
and the third one is metroidlib a
comprehensive plotting Library enabling
the creation of various visualization
such as line plots Scatter Plots
histograms and many more to explore and
present data and the fourth one is
scikitlearn a popular machine learning
library offer a broad array of
algorithms and tools for tasks like
classification regression clustering and
model Evolution and the fifth one is
Keras a high level neural network
library that simplifies the process of
building and training deep learning
models by providing initiative
abstraction and interfaces and the final
the last one is tensorflow and
extensively used deep learning library
with a flexible architecture that
enables the construction and the
training of neural network for various
tasks by mastering these essential
python liabilities you equip yourself
with the necessary tools to handle and
pre-process data efficiently visualize
insights effectively and Implement
diverse machine learning algorithm user
and deep learning models to tackle real
world problems so let's move to the step
4 which is learn and Implement various
machine learning algorithms after
gaining Proficiency in python as part of
your machine Learning Journey the
subsequent Milestone involves learning
various machine learning algorithms and
their implementation using python so
here are some of the key machine
learning algorithms that essential to
learning
first one is linear regression second
logistic regression third passive
aggressive fourth name base and fifth is
support Vector machines and number six
is decision trees 7 K nearest neighbors
8th is random Forest ninth K means and
tenth PCA which is known as principal
component analysis by mastering these
algorithm is crucial for expanding your
machine learning capabilities and
equipping yourself with the tools
necessary to effectively tackle a wide
range of data driven challenges moving
forward to the next step which is Master
the concept and implementation of
machine learning neural networks so once
you have acquired knowledge of python
and machine learning algorithms the next
significant step in the machine learning
roadmap is to learn neural network
architectures and their implementation
using python so outline here are several
crucial neural network architectures
that are essential to learning so first
one is artificial neural network and the
second one is CNN which is also known as
convolutional neural network
third one is RNN recurrent neural
networks and the fourth one is lstm long
short term memory so by understanding
and mastering these neural network
architecture you will you will gain the
expertise needed to design and Implement
powerful motors for various stocks such
as Pata recognition image classification
sequence analysis and fourth one is
natural language processing so these
architecture provide the foundation for
deep learning enabling you to build
complex model capable of learning and
making prediction from vast amount of
data and the step 6 the final step is
engage in Hands-On projects to apply
your knowledge and reinforce your
understanding so after acquiring
knowledge of python machine learning
algorithms and neural network
architectures the next crucial step in
the machine learning roadmap is to gain
practical experience by working on
projects that allow you to apply what
you want to learn for beginners it is
advisable to start with the projects
specifically designed or for beginners
so here are some machine learning
project ideas suitable for beginners the
first one is Iris flower classification
build a model to classify different
species of virus flower based on their
attributes the second one is California
house price prediction so develop a
model to predict house prices in
California using relevant features like
location square footage number of rooms
and the third one is stock price
prediction create a model to forecast
stock price based on historical data and
relevant indicators and the fourth one
is customer segmentation using
clustering techniques to group customer
base on their characteristics allow
businesses to understand their target or
audience so by working on these business
level projects you will gain hands-on
experience in data pre-processing model
development evaluation and
interpretation of result moreover these
projects provide a solid foundation
for further exploration and growth in
the field of machine learning these
projects you can find in our YouTube
channel
so with this we have come to end of this
video I hope I hope you found this video
informative and interesting if you like
this video give us thumbs up and share
it with your friends also if you have
any questions about this video please
feel free to ask in the comment section
below our team will get back to you as
soon as possible and the course covered
in this video link will be provided in
the description box do check them out
till then stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign